big story in California Governor Jerry
Brown signed the right-to-die law no
kidding are you serious yeah that's
that's right Johnny California is Johnny
our cameraman Johnny California is the
first state where it's legal for a
patient to choose to end their own life
that's great news yeah Johnny it's not
exactly great news it's still very sad
for the patient's and and their loved
ones oh no I meant it's great news for
my business
Johnny strangles run away out let Johnny
strangle show you the door I'll strangle
you in your bed I'll strangle you in
your car I'll even strangle you in the
bathroom or your favorite restaurant or
a department store any time any place
whatever your angle when you want to
wrangle a strangle just give me a jangle
Johnny strangles
I'm sorry Johnny I just can't imagine
that your business is legal it is now
sags Governor Brown and remember I can
use one hand for skinny necks or you can
get the deluxe package plus use the
promo code murder me and I'll strangle
your boss for free for free where do I
sign up
glad you asked Andy Richter visit me
online at Johnny strangles dot choke or
check out some of my work on instagram
at johnny strangles zero for its
strangling time right good luck to you
[Applause]
like so many problems with the premise
of that it sunny prop everything is that
johnny strangles one through three were
already taking yes yeah for
you